[Musique]
merci
étranger
a démontré la capacité de
cibler et de modifier de manière autonome l'orbite
d'un objet céleste l'impact de Dart
sur l'astéroïde dimorphe a été
confirmé à 19 h 14 heure de l'Est lorsque
le centre des opérations de la mission Dart ici
à l'APL a perdu le signal avec le  vaisseau spatial
maintenant normalement perdre le signal d'un
vaisseau spatial est une très mauvaise chose, mais dans
ce cas, c'était le résultat idéal
étranger
[Musique]
nous allons voir que les données
tomberont bientôt dans les deux prochains jours,
puis au cours des deux prochains  mois, nous
allons voir plus d'informations de l'
équipe d'enquête sur le changement de période que
nous avons réellement fait parce que c'est notre
deuxième objectif numéro un a été de frapper l'
astéroïde que nous avons fait mais maintenant le numéro
deux est vraiment mesurer ce changement de période
et caractériser  combien d'éjecta nous avons
réellement sorti
[Music] étrangère
pour autant que nous puissions dire que notre premier
test de défense planétaire a été un succès et
je pense que nous pouvons collaborer à cela tout le monde
d'accord, alors ouais eh bien je euh ouais je pense que
les terriens devraient mieux dormir et
certainement je vais ouais